nouveau autour de la table avant qu'on
interroge nos invités on va voir la vie
de tout le monde peut-on se moquer des
religions etc partager on a un 3 3 on
dirait voilà non mais c'est vrai c'était
intenable manchester hier alors vous
dites non christine kelly
je vais démarrer par vous parce que
c'est tombé sur abbas est tombé sur moi
bravo moi je dis non pourquoi
je comprends qu'il ya la liberté
d'expression mais liberté d'expression
n'est pas liberté d'agression c'est la
raison pour laquelle on peut rigoler de
tous à partir du moment où ne blesse pas
l'autre ne blesse pas son prochain
rires oui blessé non et j'ai me baser
moi qui suis une ancienne du csa ne
serait ce que sur un petit article sur
la publicité à la télévision qui
interdit toute publicité qui peut
heurter toutes convictions religieuses
dans l enseigne un article à noyelles 30
cycle ballack a interdit toutes les
publicités à la télévision qui peuvent
heurter toutes mes convictions
religieuses je me base sur ça pour dire
que oui à la liberté d'expression
on peut rigoler on peut rigoler de la
religion mais attention liberté d'
agression non alors eric naulleau
peut-on se moquer des religions oui en
france on a parlé tout à l'heure d'un
symbole de la france qui était notre
dame et deux autres symboles liés à la
liberté d'expression et le fait que le
blasphème n'existe pas mais à ce que
propose christine c'est assez redoutable
parce que la vexation s'est pas
seulement pour les croyants faut donc
interdire tout humour qui vexerait qui
froid serait une quelconque personne
donc c'est fini
faut abolir l'humour moi c'est pas dans
ce monde là que je veux vivier pas dit
de continuer à vivre ensemble
même si le fils y avait je veux
continuer à vivre en france veut
continuer à ce que certaines blagues ne
fasse pas rire en france on peut sauver
notre dame et on peut se moquer de notre
dame comme l'a fait charlie le lendemain
de l'incendié où le veau le surlendemain
et c'est ça qui définit la france donc
c'est un autre pays que tu veux moi je
veux rester dans cet ailleurs patrick
peloux a failli venir nous voir
voilà qu'on embrasse patrick que j'aime
fort et malheureusement il n'a pas pu
aujourd'hui il fera peut-être d'autres
balances ton poste avec nous monsieur
laporte
donc je suis entièrement d'accord avec
moi je veux vivre dans une société où on
rigole où on se moque au bon sens du
terme il n'y a pas d'agressivité
ce mode d'émotion dans les vestiaires
les biches coup sûr mon canari bieber
soit il ya de tout il ya toutes les
religions confondues pour des petits et
des plus grands il ya des gros etc et on
rigole un hasard et chacun d'eux se
moque de l'autre en permanence mais
c'est ça fait parti d'un bien vivre
ensemble c'est pas de l'agressivité
c'est comme tout honneur c'est qu'elle
s'est fait avec avec p investi avec rire
avec dérision avec seymour ça passe bien
mieux effectivement quand c'est dans
l'agressivité
agatha je suis totalement d'accord avec
bernard et je crois moi ce qui se passe
quelque chose de très grave c'est qu'on
se dirige vers une société de
l'indignation systématique et de la
censure et de l'autocensure
ce qui est très grave j'ai l'impression
qu'on ne peut plus rien dire plus rien
faire sans se prendre immédiatement des
réactions disproportionnées de tous les
côtés parce que on aurait été trop loin
ou heurter quelque peu en fait derrière
l'humour la dérision c'est pas un crime
l'humour c'est pas un crime on a pris
l'exemple du tweet du gros et en plus il
ya eu un déferlement sur ce twitt mais
je crois que personne n'a eu la
référence de la vanne qu'il essayait de
faire ce qu'il a fait référence à une
souris
le père john deere moi j'adore cette
émission et moi aussi j'adore mais n'ont
pu te dire pardon
personne n'a compris laval personne ne
connaît et hugo mais juste parce qu'ils
s'étaient emparés d'un symbole religieux
tout de suite il a été taxé de racisme
l'islamophobie d'agression alors que
l'humour n'est pas une agression il n'y
a pas de message cheminots dernière s'il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas de volonté de
division au contraire c'est une volonté
de rire ensemble et je pense que si
chacun faisait preuve d'un peu plus de
dérision sur soi même mais on serait
tellement on sentirait tellement mieux
mais tous dans la vie en communauté
alors j'aimerais dans la vie de jimmy
également de modèles de mohamed dû me
mohamed qu'on soit vraiment dit
réellement mais c'est son nom bre série
que sont famille s'appelle jimmy et
tournon famille c'est mohamed j'adore
exactement vous êtes mon idole
voilà je vous ai menti alors vous pensez
que longuet mis à sac c'est une position
compliquée à défendre pas se mentir
alors d'un côté on aurait la bonne
société
prenez par eric naulleau qui me dit que
bah si on veut pas de celle ci bat
finalement est un peu des terroristes
intellectuels et qu'on voudrait vivre en
iran ou en afghanistan
c'est pas du tout ça mais six ans c'est
un peu ce que tu sous-entends moi je
pense comme un enfant tu pars pas la
belgique
tu parles d'un pays évidemment
le glas le blasphème n'existe pas donc
on a le droit d'insulter une religion
mais on entend beaucoup d'humoristes
dire que l'humour s'arrête appartement
vous blesser les gens et moi c'est vrai
que quand on parle notamment des
communautés j'en ai marre des blacks sud
est asiatique ce n'est pas la longueur
de leurs saisies sur le fait qu'ils
travaillent beaucoup moi ça me fait pas
rire j'en ai marre qu'on se moque des
maghrébins en disant voilà la boîte à ma
croûte quand ma mère n'est pas l'argent
bah oui votre ta maman l'a pas eu
d'argent je vais pas citer le comédien
qui fait beaucoup de blagues sur ses
parents moi je trouve pas ça drôle
j'en ai marre qu'on se moque aussi des
noirs j'en ai marre qu'on se moque ce ça
me fait pas rire parce que c'est un
fonds de commerce
ils ont droit de le faire des gens ont
le droit d'y aller c'est la liberté
d'expression de la même façon moi je
suis blessé quand joie alors charlie
hebdo c'est très compliqué de parler du
charlie hebdo bien sûr je cautionne pas
ce qui s'est passé mais quand je vois
des unes sur nos amis catholiques où on
fait passer les catholiques pour des
pédophiles
alors oui à la pédophilie ça existe oui
mais dans toutes les religions mais
quand systématiquement associés
catholicisme ap de fini bah ça me
dérange de la même façon on associe la
religion musulmane aux terroristes de la
même façon qu'on associe nos amis juifs
à l'argent au fait d'être annaba moi ça
me dérange pas donc je voulais et ça me
dérange et ça me blesse c'est quand ça
me blesse me dis que ça peut aussi
blessé mon voisin ça et donc si ça
blesse nos voisins c'est parce qu'il
faut peut-être s'arrêter là alors on
envoie là j'attends tout de suite les
gens de dire que je suppose une société
totalitaire nantes votre un peu plus si
je le dis moi bah moi je comprends qu'on
prend la vie de jimmy qui dit quand ça
blesse des gens n'a pas fait que c'est
pas drôle ça peut la limite cela les
andré bercoff on peut pas dire ça je
crois que c'est un problème extrêmement
grave
il faut revenir à l'histoire alors oui
c'est toujours erreur et elle y revient
toujours un historien ou tafer et est-ce
que qui vais descendre et dribblait
alain decaux mais oui absolument
qui va décider de qui blessent qui les
juge moi je vais vous dire un truc très
simple c'est qu'à partir du moment
normal le juge on n'est pas dans une
société policière et les pales ce hit et
juridictionnelles je rappelle quelque
chose
pierre desproges il ya 30 ans 40 ans cl
il disait à un moment donné y lisait
veulent semer on me dit que quelques
juifs se sont glissés dans la salle et
ben justement on à la vidéo mais parfait
vous avez préparé l'émission
oui bien sûr dont vous avez beaucoup de
chance bercoff regarder
cependant on me dit que des juifs se
sont glissés dans la salle
n'empêche qu'on ne m'ôtera pas de l'idée
que pendant la dernière guerre mondiale
de nombreux juifs ont une attitude
carrément hostiles à l'égard du régime
nazi
il est vrai que les allemands de leur
côté ne cachait pas une certaine
antipathie à l'égard des juifs mais
enfin ça n'était pas une raison pour
exacerber cette antipathie en armant une
étoile à sa veste pour montrer qu'on
n'est pas n'importe qui on est le peuple
élu et pourquoi j'y réponds était au
vélodrome d'hiver
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ces wagons
semble enquête
et giraudoux 6e inouïe juste un mot je
voulais continuer là-dessus aujourd'hui
c'est impensable aujourd'hui figure et
que ça sur les juifs ou les musulmans
etc vous ayez 40 associations qui leur
tournent vers ce sketch à jean vilar et
drapeaux d'ivoire sombre mais non
monsieur venu parce que non mais 2010 on
constate deux petites secondes peaux
demandé aux rabbins jonas jacquelin est
ce qu est ce que ça vous fait marrer
vous du sketch où est ce que ça vous
dérange
alors quand on le prend dans le contexte
de l'époque je pense quelque chose
d'assez drôle parce que en réalité quand
je vois un sketch comme celui là je me
dis ce dont ils se moquent sont les
antisémites banal jeu est fait et ça
ouais eh bien j'ai je pense que quand on
analyse quand on écoute ce qui dit c'est
ça la réalité c'est pas le fait de
pointer les quelques juifs dans la salle
mais c'est le fait de pointer le fait
que dans l'esprit de certains il puisse
y avoir quelque chose de dérangeant à ça
et l'humour c'est toujours lié à
l'intelligence est toujours lié à la
compétition vous courir vous si vous
étiez grâce à vous aurez et bollène
écoutez je pense que oui mais vous
n'étiez pas né leurs problèmes s'ils
existaient 86 pour la pratique pour les
séries alors oui bonsoir oui bonsoir
surexcités c'est extrêmement important
est grave parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a
une tendance formidable qui dit attendez
faut plus parler de rien il va faire
très attention et hop
or moi je vous dis pirae premier amour
quand même faut briser le maire de
laisser le philly à une volonté de
censure il volonté de police de la
pensée et je veux dire c'est passionnant
sur la logique même si ce sujet
toutankhamon il ya l'exposition
toutankhamon croyait lui parce que
toutankhamon j'ai été voir ce spectacle
c'est une cata j'aurais pu le voir
toutankhamon est bizarre on lit on y
l'origine africain toutankhamon tout à
coup et égyptien l'egypte est l'égyptien
ac ou l'egypte c'est pas au pôle nord
c'est à l'afrique
leschi il ya eu un certain nombre de
choses qui consiste mais oui je veux
dire il ya eu des gens qui ont dit ces
racistes
vous avez oublié de dire que
toutankhamon et paix africains conneries
total qui a dit ça mais il ya un groupe
un groupuscule qui a dit ça et qui en a
parlé parce que ce n'est pas l'humour il
a eu des presses non non c'est très
important mais en fait c'est les phrases
que vous deviez platine
un défi sur twitter qui tue j'étudie
toutankhamon il a 5 euros de plus autre
comme ça c'est charlie hebdo il ya eu 15
morts
parce que il s'est attaqué a appris la
mort quasiment non il faut oublier c'est
pas un petit truc quand même temps que
vous dites est pas une rigolade on met
donc vous dites on peut se moquer des
religions ou pas je dit c'est le sauve
au fait du tout on peut se moquer de
tout et si les gens sont blessés
ils n'ont qu'à ne pas écouter voilà
c'est très simple on est dans un pays de
liberté il a une visite passionnante en
doute que ce soit religion ou pas rien
et au dessus pour l'apa le le délit de
blasphème n'existe pas en france et
heureusement parce que c'est une
démocratie on sait très bien dans quelle
fille il suffit de d'assurer des
religions pour être torturés ou
emprisonnés ou marie calme après j'aurai
en attendant un bus utrecht âgées pour
deux raisons d'abord parce que je pense
qu'on est dans l'opposition de sacrée la
liberté d'expression elle est sacrée
dans notre pays par l'histoire et on
touche au sacré quand on touche aux
religions pour les croyants de dans
cette opposition des sacrés je suis
assez partagé parce que je me dis oh de
brand dans mon pays la france où la
liberté d'expression est sacrée on doit
pouvoir se moquer des religions mais en
même temps je considère que la moquerie
elle dérive souvent sur l'humiliation
sur le sentiment d' insulte sur même
j'ai envie de dire de l'obsession parce
qu'on a parfois des choix éditoriaux des
choix humoristique qui tourne à
l'obsession dans notre pays aujourd'hui
de kir se demander si c'est encore dans
le sens de l'humour on se demande si ce
ne sont pas des messages d'un
subliminaux qui ont une dimension
politique
tu penses à côté oui c'est quoi quoi
tiennent quel exemple je pense par
exemple à des gens qui sous couvert
d'antisémitisme on fait de l'humour donc
et à calibrer il
ils prennent toujours les juifs en
obsession je pense à ceux qui prennent
toujours l'islam et les musulmans
et donc il ya des gens aujourd'hui qui
en font un fonds de commerce qui n'est
plus rigolo bien son fils devrait
effectivement préfère ce que certains
c'est pour ça que merci je suis interdit
de rêver tous ces projets là uniquement
et pas religieuse au mas de la réalité
c'est que encore une fois j'ai les
sentiments faux cul qu'on doit pouvoir
effectivement dans l'expression être
libre dans notre pays parce qu'il faut
quand même dire qu'en thaïlande mais si
tu te moques de bouddha tu vas en prison
aux etats-unis de pâques tu peux te
moquer de jésus mais je suis surtout que
maintenant tu as excuse moi je te je te
donnerai les éléments il ya des gens qui
se sont fait dans certains états
américains
parce que chahuté de cas et dans
certains pays musulmans tu peux pas te
manque effectivement de l'argent mais il
me semble moi il me semble que moi qui
suis croyant je me dis est-ce que -
sacré je dois l'imposer à autrui
je me pose la question est-ce que ce qui
est sacré pour moi je dois l'imposer à
celui qui ne partagent pas la même ça
criait tu vas pas de réponse est que et
il ay qui je suis en application
je viens de te dire que la liberté
d'expression est une valeur sacrée dans
mon pays et que demain tu truc les
mollahs jouer mais les amis à leur égard
je suis désolé très désolé sacrée cote
il a vécu quatre avec un ordre qui est
très clivant quant à l'abus toulouse 2-2
de limiter chose de cas à la démagogie
moi je vous dis que c'est un sujet qu'on
actuelle les couleurs de chaises c'est
qu'on peut y aller pas son tour fin
c'est ce que vous dites pas que l'on ne
pas s'exprimer sans offenser manar
traverse pas l'esprit et l'humour c'est
le mot c'est l'humour
comme j'habite humour oui mais oui mais
au ps en fait on se calme oui la dune 2
et mangeraient pas de l'humour c'est
l'amour et marvin gaye chardonnerets
pendant mes pas oublier d une de charlie
hebdo qui m'ont choqué c'est pour ça que
je vais demander l'intervention 15 morts
oui mais simplement je vous disais que
donc ne pas imposer effectivement donc
son sacré à autrui et peut-être que les
croyants quelles que soient les
religions devrait prendre de la distance
et ben voilà avec cette forme d'humour
effectivement peut faire mal parfait